man I haven't seen a pixie stick in
Forever they make those things anymore
pull your pants down
just long and skinny yeah yeah I've got
a 4 45 inch dick that's half a
centimeter wide centimeter circumference
what do you have like a lobotomy penis
like that and it ended up being like the
perfect penis what do you mean like what
if it just like got to like a G-spot or
something like that was perfectly it's
just so precise oh yeah and it was yeah
yeah he's the love doctor the biggest
thing yeah the kebab and he penetrates a
lady and it's just a one in like Matrix
Jack where he just like gets in there
she's like oh
it's like
convulsing